I am sorry  I had no idea that was your cab  you got to believe me I I hope I didn't  cause you any inconvenience  let me make it up to you somehow huh  please  how about a nice hot dog and a beer  uh no thanks just a hot dog then no I'm  fine thank you couple of beers ah we'll  kill some time suck back a few Brew you  know have a pickled egg or two huh sound  good  not really I'm fine  how about a nice bag of jubes um  I'm kind of picky about what I eat  toffees then a nice bag of toffees  everybody loves toffees I love toffees  sir  is that seat taken  some sourdough bread they make it fresh  you know in San Francisco they sell it  at all the airports it's very good you  probably have some already I usually  carry a couple loafs with me but if you  want I'll get you a loaf sir please just  let me know I'm here  he knew I knew you  know something